the story of Paul Pelosi a tragedy
a man struck him in the head with a
hammer I mean it's a brutal attack I'm
glad that he's getting better
Nancy Pelosi gave a heartfelt interview
saying that this was a contributing
factor into why she may retire or it
could be that the Dem the Democrats just
lost the house formally it is now
confirmed Republicans have taken control
they knew they had control they were
already having those meetings but now
something interesting has happened a
story came out from The Today Show they
deleted it they never issued a formal
retraction they said it just wasn't up
to their standards but didn't give an
explanation where uh Paul Pelosi
apparently opened the door for the cops
didn't complain didn't say there was an
emergency calmly walked back to this man
and then fought him and it's very
confusing
well they pulled that video down we now
have a new report coming out confirming
much of those details leaving many to
question why it was that NBC pulled
their story could it be they pulled it
before the midterms and other midterms
are over the story is fair game again
I don't know man but we're going to talk
about it because it is weird to say the
least
we also have some other stories that are
quite fun and and funny the Democrats
are already trying to invoke the 14th
Amendment to stop Trump from being able
to run for office which is just nonsense
insanity and uh zelenski is uh I can
only say I guess trying to invoke world
war three because even after NATO said
hey guys that missile strike actually
Ukrainian big mistake zielinski is like
no no no
so hopefully this man doesn't drag us
into World War III but he's now being
criticized by even members of NATO that
that he's too overzealous and needs to
calm down
we get it before we get started my
friends head over to timcast.com become
a member by clicking that join us button
and you'll get access to exclusive
uncensored uncensored episodes of this
Show timcast irrel members only Monday
through Thursday at 11 PM as well as the
cast Castle vlog
we are producing this uh sitcom style
fake Vlog of the of the office and it's
a it's getting better and better as we
as we figure things out and improve on
the show so if you want to watch silly
Shenanigans meet all of the people who
work here and watch Ian well I can't
describe what Ian did in that last
episode because he probably been on
YouTube but it's funny so uh definitely
become a member at timcast.com and also
click the store and I'll also pin this
in the chat and pick up your super Maga
t-shirt
look I went on to the AI the the stable
diffusion AI thing and I said Donald
Trump going Super Saiyan and it made
this and I was like this is the coolest
thing ever and so we decided to make it
a t-shirt comma Gama God and it's Donald
Trump going Super Saiyan no joke that's
an AI generated image that's I thought
that was really cool so if you want to
get Donald Trump going Super Saiyan I
noticed a lot of people were sharing the
image and I'm like cool I'm glad I ran I
typed something random into an AI image
generator and now people are having a
good time with it so uh pick that up in
the store and I'll also pin it in the
chat for you guys to see joining us to
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends uh um you can yeah joining us
today we're gonna get into it joining us
today to talk about a whole bunch of
stuff is Michael Graves yeah thanks for
having me yeah who ours is awesome
thanks for coming man uh well um um my
claim to fame is I joined the Misfits in
1995 left in 2001 and continued my
musical Journey onward
um gleefully canceled in 2004 for a host
of things including saying the word
Jesus
yeah well
my family's very upset with me
uh but yeah you know my my I'm like the
Forrest Gump of music so there you go
um yeah yeah it's who I am you did crazy
man you do great work Miss Fitz Awesome
by the way thank you super excited to
have you here it's gonna be fun we also
got Luke wearing a shirt with Karl Marx
on it hey guys um as you know my family
barely survived communism that's why
today I'm wearing one of my favorite
t-shirts it's it's wonderful to wear at
hippie uh Yuppie areas you see the
Barista see the shirt do you see the
glimmer of hope and happiness and then
he reads the quote on the bottom that
says gives me that by some homeless guy
uh which is a t-shirt that is awesome if
you want to experience this amazing
moment with your fellow Baristas you
could get the shirt on the best
politicalshirts.com because you do this
is why I'm here and this is definitely
worth a real life troll that is really
fun to put on the yuppies
I like that a lot Gibbs give me dads
gives me that give me debts uh hey guys
I want to Echo what Tim was saying about
cast Castle it's awesome we this last
weekend I shot with corn nemec we shot
over the weekend uh hilarious episode if
you know coronemic from Stargate sg1
Parker Lewis I mean he was on the show
last week the guy's amazing and it was
really fun to make the week before we
did a hilarious long-form longer form
one about a chess tournament you were
going to want to see so if you haven't
signed up for that yet and got a whiff
of this stuff your get involved is
freaking hilarious it's a joy to be a
part of and Wesley's a genius director
he's really easy and fun to work with
I'm looking forward to making more uh
and they're they're I mean Crossland you
know that see ya what's up dude oh look
who's back hey what's up YouTubers I'm
still here I'm still alive nothing crazy
happened don't worry about it I'm Matt
serge.com as well by the way let's get
into this first story
wow Bay Area NBC station is running
report questioning the circumstances of
Paul Pelosi's Hammer attack which
include the same details as Today's Show
segment retracted for inaccuracies and
left star reporter Miguel
almaguer as I pronounce it suspended
this is particularly interesting they
say NBC News is under mounting pressure
to explain its actions after suspending
star reporter Miguel almaguer over one
of his Today Show segments on the Paul
Pelosi Hammer attack
it took the action despite a second
report on the company owned and operated
NBC bay area station that repeats many
of the same points in almaguer's report
they're going to mention that NBC
removed the footage from its website
hours after anger November 4th now we do
have another report from from Fox News
and this is what they mentioned that's
very very uh interesting I want to read
this one NBC News National con
correspondent reported on November 4th
for today's for uh The Today Show that
police didn't know they were responding
to the Pelosi residents Pelosi opened
the door for police but didn't attempt
to escape or declare an emergency and
even walked away from law enforcement
and toured his eventual attacker they go
on a mention last Friday exactly one
week after all McGuire's report was
mysteriously retracted with little
public detail NBC San Francisco local
affiliate which is branded as NBC bay
area aired an explosive Report with
highly similar details indicating Pelosi
opened the door for police and didn't
immediately attempt to escape
so the initial story someone broke into
pulp into the Pelosi residence screamed
where's Nancy in his underwear with zip
ties and struck Paul on the head now
then then turned into he okay he was
actually clothed
okay a third man opened the door but we
don't know what it was they changed the
story again and now the Today Show comes
out and says Paul Pelosi opens the door
doesn't try to escape walks back to the
guy who says there's nothing going on
and then who strikes him
and now the story is being confirmed
after the uh or again I should say after
the Today Show retracted uh not even
formally retracted just deleted the
video
I have to wonder
what really happened of course the
theory from the right is that it was a
late night either drug deal or love romp
gone wrong and the police responded and
you know lover's quarrel of some sort I
think drug deal makes more sense which
is why they're they're you know let's 3
A.M Paul Pelosi is like send in the
crazy weirdo guy who's got the drugs
fight breaks out over cash or something
like that who knows or
maybe the police didn't know they were
responding to Paul Pelosi's house they
opened the door and they attacked Paul
Pelosi because he was in his underwear
and they assumed it must be a crazy guy
or something maybe the cops are the ones
who hit him and then they're trying to
cover up their story I I feel like if
the cops hit him we would be seeing like
uh defund the police part two right
nobody knows what happened it sounds
like two drunk dudes at a bar like just
you know people can get belligerent late
night when they're both really hammered
and they don't even know what they're
talking about that one guy just gets
angry and then they're like and then
they just start to bump into each other
like that's what it sounds like well
David and Paul were doing well
personally I'm just sick of the
speculating I don't want to speculate
anymore release the body cam footage
release the surveillance footage then we
could actually know what happened here
otherwise you don't give the government
any benefit of the doubt we're talking
about career criminals who parade
themselves around like some high-level
politicians and officials they're not
these people are up to some really nasty
stuff we're talking about so much
corruption within the uh Losi family
we're talking about so much money that
they earned off of America's back
they're probably you know when it comes
to government officials and people
connected to them we should always think
the worst possible scenario always go
with that until we actually have some
actual evidence they were doing
unspeakable things to small babies they
were sacrificing children let's let's
just go with that if we're going to be
speculating what happened here let's
think of the worst thing because we
shouldn't be given government any kind
of credence any kind of leeway here and
with this story being so crazy insane
they were doing god-awful things to
small babies that's it I just assume the
worst I guess yeah absolutely and you
should what government because what
government does is probably usually a
lot worse than what we actually know
actually really happens so Paul's not
government he's only government adjacent
government adjacent well that's just as
bad that's just as bad how did he make
all of his money yeah because of his
connections to to government obviously
that's pretty clear allegedly it's not
even it's not even alleged they make
better calls on the stock market than
Warren Buffett okay you don't get that
lucky it's impossible to be that lucky
like the Pelosi's have been so come on
we know what it is maybe this guy
this the pop guy was his inside source
on Wall Street and that's how he was
making his money and he was telling him
to invest in FTX and Paul was like no
you screwed me that's the problem is
that we're able to speculate on this
story we're able to sit here and try to
figure out what happened and how did
everybody get in their underwear and why
weren't the cops there and the third in
line to the presidency there's somebody
getting their underwear yeah where did
the hammer come from and I can't believe
that nobody is selling hammers online
like the Paul Pelosi Hammer uh
right yeah and help you win a chess
match perhaps
correctly it's some Insider yeah
uh but I but that's the thing all of
this speculation could be over with if
if the government released the body Cam
and released the actual information that
is out there and give us the clear story
and we are not getting the clear story
because what this is Paul once again is
this an excuse for Nancy to retire and
try and score points like
I don't understand it seems to me like
happened that they're trying to cover it
up it really seems to me like it was
something that went wrong like you said
maybe it was a bad drug deal or they
they were getting weird together who
knows and then and then the cleanup team
came in they were just like all right
now what are we gonna do we gotta we
gotta make this look like something and
then the the script writers came in and
and said all right well let's make it
like this because think about how much
power is being wielded by these people
and many times Hollywood does work with
the Pentagon when it comes to scripting
narratives we have seen time and time
again something happens in Iraq and
they're like okay what can we say
actually happened what really happened
those are two completely different
things how can we use this event to and
change it for the best PR purposes we
saw that with Jessica Lynch we saw that
with Mainline Hollywood directors and
producers getting involved and saying
you know what this story of of the
Iraqis taking her to a hospital and
trying to help her does it really fit
our narrative let's send in the tanks
and let's say that they were holding her
hostage again they made so much things
up when it came to to war they make so
much things up when it comes to just our
everyday life everything from them
should be seen as fake nothing should be
believed by government or the
authorities until we actually have some
real life evidence that we can back up
their statements on because they are
pathological Liars satanic individuals
some of them that do awful things that
we can't even imagine how terrible they
are I'm okay
you know I'm sitting here and I see this
story and it's a crazy story
and I'm trying to figure out why
whatever it is they're doing matters so
much they don't want anyone to know
about it
you're like like they suspended a star
reporter from The Today Show for
reporting what now sounds to be fact
what is so important about this moment
that this incident that they don't want
us to know about it that's this is the
crazy thing because I kind of look at
this and I'm like
whatever Paul Pelosi is doing I don't
care about right yeah but to go to this
degree
it sounds like something they were doing
must have mattered like politically or
something I think I think it's it's an
effort to to fend off what these who
these people really are the depravity
they just don't want their true colors
to to show even though we all know it
obviously this man
abuses some sort of substances or
something going on these people are not
on the up and up at least booze yeah
from what we know about publicly on the
record we got busted driving drunk like
within six months ago or something and
that's a problem if someone especially
in their 80s is driving home drunk
enough to get him I mean not even drunk
enough just drunk in general I've driven
drunk a couple times in my life it was
probably some of the worst I was like
near suicidal at that period of my life
too like step on the gas and just wait
for it to happen kind of suicidal and
that is a bad State of Mind to drive
drunk if someone's like if you don't
have that kind of self-control where you
can be like I actually have to drive I'm
gonna put it down that's indicates a big
problem psychologically so I imagine the
guys got maybe obvious look the midterms
this this happens right before the
midterms yeah they pulled the story
after the midterms story pops back up on
an NBC affiliate it could just really be
it makes the Pelosi's look freaky and
weird and it was bad for Democrats
Republicans were running the story that
there was a gay love romp or something
and they wanted to shut it down so NBC
colluding you know or or seeking to help
maybe not colluding Democrats pulls the
story until after the midterms that
could be it it could really be as simple
as Paul Pelosi is a weirdo does freaky
things in the middle of night yeah I
think that's for sure I mean not for
sure but I think that's the case but the
connection to January 6 see how it's
it's connected to January 6th he walked
in there and and was saying where's
where's Nancy where's Nancy oh well of
course he was saying that that's another
Point that's all the that's all those
people are gonna hear that's all the the
libs are gonna hear like oh but so the
question is did they twist an existing
story to make it sound like Insurrection
sure or did they fabricate a story to
try and win points before an election I
think it's exactly what what I said
before something happened
the truth happened that was something
that has to do with depravity nobody
broke into that house the only just
broke into that house started walking
around with a hammers held up in the
bathroom that's craziness story keeps
changing so at this point I'm not
inclined to believe what their version
is yeah and the fact that Paul Pelosi
was not threatened when the cops
answered the dorm that's the new detail
now being confirmed you know clearly the
news is again knew this guy there's got
to be cameras in that house right if
that dude was running around his
underwear going where's Nancy where's
Nancy we would see it over and over and
over that's true that first propaganda
purposes they would of course weaponize
that footage and have it everywhere so
we couldn't ignore it we always have to
see it everywhere and we saw the
corporate media after this being like
it's the conspiracy thermostat that are
the problem here they're the ones that
are crazy they're the ones that we have
to stop they're the ones that we have to
go over we have to make sure that people
can't be able to speak to each other and
now they're punishing journalists like
this Miguel reporter by the way this
reporter uh Miguel ala margar hasn't
tweeted since November 4th he's the one
that got suspended for originally
reporting the story which we talked
about on the show that was specifically
based on police sources what's happening
to him I want to hear from this guy
Miguel if you're out there what's going
on here because this is absolutely crazy
what kind of story you're involved I'll
tell you about conspiracy theories
there's there's a tweet I can't remember
who I saw this as a verified Twitter
account saying that uh Putin is pushing
an insane conspiracy theory that the
missile that hit Poland was Ukrainian we
can't allow Russian disinformation blah
blah blah sure enough turns out even the
West is now saying exactly that so we'll
definitely get into the Ukraine stuff in
a minute but I just want to point that
out when they come out and they're like
it's a conspiracy theory don't believe
it typically that means you know I
better look into that because uh you
can't believe these people but uh I
think politics may have played played a
role let's jump into the next story
because I think it's funny that the lead
for this podcast was not Republicans
take control of the House NBC News
projects so it is now formally confirmed
uh we we knew this was going to happen
that's why we're all saying yeah we get
it Republicans won the house but now
it's formalized there's no recounts
Nothing's Gonna Change the only question
now is how many seats will the
Republicans actually gain in the end of
this it's looking like 219 but it could
actually be a little bit more depending
on recounts and we'll see but uh I just
want to point out this is massive
they're already talking about
investigating fauci
and we and the lead for the show is like
Paul Pelosi has weird you know lovers
trist romp Hammer attack or something
like that
because I kind of well I guess I guess
we kind of knew the Republicans were
gonna take that but the question that I
guess for everybody else is
how excited are you on a scale of uh one
to ten I am three only because I when I
think of this issues and what we're
going through right now we've talked a
lot about left and right and blue and
red but I'm starting to think it's
actually like um an economic plan that's
happening right now it's it's very
um complicated there's lots of people
with lots of different ideologies making
moves and trying to take control and
they want us to think that it's a binary
thing between them and us but really
it's a bunch of different economic
pressures so this stuff is kind of like
the mask that we are talking about that
was is being created in my opinion by
the villain if it's a villain you know
if there's going to be a villain maybe
I'm the villain one to ten how how much
I'm excited for the Republicans is that
what you're asking for them for them
gaining control of the house zero I
don't think it's gonna matter I didn't
say zero to ten I said one through ten
Luke come on
they're not going to change any it's not
going to do anything and the Republicans
have been you don't think they're gonna
go after fouchy yeah
in the house yes they have subpoena
power and investigatory power I'd be
very surprised if they do I've already
started talking about doing come on you
got Thomas Massey in the house he'll
he'll do something Rand Paul's
apparently having meetings as well he's
in the Senate I know he doesn't have the
same power but it's not looking too good
what what do you think they did they did
choose McCarthy and and McConnell for a
leadership exactly so I I Echo Luke's
sentiment I would go with the one I want
I just don't think it just does I don't
think that
they I hate saying they I just don't
think that they will let us win
I think it's it leans towards like the Q
and on stuff like where you go all right
we got the house now we got all our
people in here we go we're gonna
investigate fauci's going down we're
going after this guy we're coming out
with our hammers uh touche you know and
and and and once again it's setting us
up for for this disappointment when we
need to be saying looking at the reality
of it
unless well I I look I am I'm certainly
not a one I'm not gonna pretend like
Republicans coming in uh pushing
McCarthy and McConnell to the top again
is any kind of real Victory but 31
members of the House did reject McCarthy
so there may be some leverage from the
free I think it was mostly the freedom
caucus they were basically like nope
yeah I think we'll see some stuff look
we're not gonna We're Not Gonna uh win
everything instantly but I'm feeling
pretty good I mean it's look it's better
than Democrats doing January sex
hearings I agree and and I think and I'm
not completely sure on the process but
uh the the vote for leadership doesn't
take place until January I think until
they reconvene and well they did you
mean for the party for the house they
yeah they I think oh oh it's right it's
nomination I think is that what happened
I think so no no no no no I think I
think I think McConnell is he did win
didn't he
I don't know someone factual I'm pretty
sure they they've they've already had
the vote Matt Gates I think maybe not
Matt Gates
um and someone and I can't remember who
in the Senate were trying to get a
postponed saying like I think it might
have been Holly I'm not sure yeah saying
like we should wait on this but I'm
pretty sure they did maybe I'm thinking
of the house it says Mitch McConnell
wins secret ballot election to continue
leading Senate Republicans seven hours
ago yeah yeah from Seattle I know that's
just my wishful thinking I've got like
this feeling like if we're talking about
the future of humanity that it's a big
Global project and we as Americans a lot
of us are stuck in the American
perspective where we're only looking at
ourselves and that if we can do this
then the whole world will win but like I
think there are a lot of people in the
rest of the world are looking at us like
goofballs obsessed with the circus that
we're in right now and like hey you know
let's let's exit the circus and look
around
sort of so so one to ten what are you
Tim
McCarthy well so far from MacArthur I
mean this is essentially what you tried
to get me then no no no that's why I
said zero I'm excited that there's a
small handful of Republicans who can
have some pressure ability but uh I'll
put it this way if if one is I'm
extremely disappointed ten as I'm
excited as I ever have been and five is
kind of yeah I'll say six
you know like when you say one you're
saying like I'm mad about this this is
the worst thing ever this is bad for us
five is where you're like meh I say six
I'm cautiously optimistic that the the
circumstances we have to look forward to
with Democrats is more January 6
nonsense waste of our time things that
no one cares about with Republicans it's
like okay I guess hopefully they'll
start talking about fauci or some maybe
not but whatever the January 6th stuff
is done yeah it's subjective because I
just don't see any kind of larger
Solutions out there I don't see them
making life better for the average
American especially with McCarthy uh
just controlling everything he's going
to be protecting a lot of people inside
the establishment and making sure that
the Republicans aren't too wild aren't
too crazy don't make too much uh crazy
uh moves so so he's there to keep
everyone in line and I think that's
exactly what they're going to be doing
here and it's not like they have a lot
of wiggle room here they barely were
able to win this so as far as my
optimism and politics it's none my
optimism is with the people of the
United States it's with local officials
local individuals taking charge of their
life and being responsible for
themselves rather than giving all of
their power and authority and money to
politicians that don't give a damn about
it okay okay no I agree on a lot of
those points we have this other story
from timcast.com that goes along with
this house Democrats maneuver to stop
Trump's 2024 presidential bid house rep
cites the 14th amendment's Insurrection
Clause as basis to deny return to high
office
this is what we have to look forward to
if the Democrats were trained retained
control of the house that's a good point
they'd be just going the 14th Amendment
man they'd be banging on the walls we we
ought to pad the walls to help them out
because you think they can't get a
republican to flip in the house I think
they can I think they still could go
forward with this and then they just go
to the Republican and be like you know
that trip you made to that Island you
know those videotapes we have on here
are you gonna vote with us or do you do
you want some larger expose on TMZ what
do you want there or they'll go to
McCarthy be like look McCarthy we'll
we'll give you you know something we'll
give you a little bit but we want to
make sure this happens McCarthy would be
for this we got to understand this yeah
Old Republic at that point would be for
this so this is why again I don't have a
lot of Hope right and and meanwhile they
have the media in their pocket and so as
they're doing that they're churning out
the narrative and they're just once
again corralling the truth which puts us
in a very difficult position when we
have things like nuclear war what's
happening with in the medical side of
things what's happening to to to all of
us our country is being destroyed
by the Democrats and Republicans by both
sides by both parties it's a new opoly
it's a two-party system that that
pretends to be fighting each other most
of the time sometimes they really do
fight but most of the times it's all
pretend it's all WWE it's all
entertainment it's all Showmanship but
that feels a little archaic to me I mean
I I agree mostly but since Donald Trump
got into office we started seeing a
whole bunch of libertarian and America
First candidates I'm not saying they
overlap they're they're both
anti-establishment factions the house
Freedom caucus where Ron DeSantis I
believe he helped found it has been
pushing back and expanding within their
within the Republican party so that's
what I'm looking at obviously I'm not
excited for Mitch McConnell no one likes
this guy this is the funny thing I
pulled up the Civics polls and went
through every single demographic not a
single demographic views him favorably
not even Republicans
how's this guy leading the charge
because there's because there's they're
all cowards exactly there's a reason FTX
was donating not only overwhelmingly to
Democrats but also to the GOP people
don't forget a lot of when it comes to
this larger FTX story which is I think
very important you don't just see the
the Democrats being bought off here you
see about 23 million dollars going
specifically to the Republicans as well
so a big money plays a lot of influence
in our politics and we have to
understand once we get rid of that
influence once we get rid of that money
then we could actually have some real
conversations but at the end of the day
these Representatives aren't
representing us they're representing a
special interest that bought them off
paid them off and they're going to be
doing their bidding no matter what and
there is some infighting sure but but
even before that there was the Tea Party
there was Essence of people saying this
is crazy that we're dealing with these
two parties here that are controlling
our dialogue that are controlling our
life we need to stop this because this
is how they fool and kid everyone to
vote for the lesser of two evils while
always presenting evil and I'm just sick
of it I'm not going to sit here and
defend the GOP leadership or their party
or anything like that I'm only excited
for the small faction of like the
freedom caucus and the people who are
actually pushing back obviously
the fact that they've chosen McCarthy
and McConnell for leadership it shows
you exactly where this Congress is going
to be
and it's unfortunate that's reality
you're going to get a whole bunch of
Republicans saying like no now now we
can't go off investigating Joe Biden
because we're going to take the high
road and just let them do whatever they
want or it's going to be more like we we
got to take the high road on this and
not investigate have it help me if they
find out how I was involved
yeah they're they're definitely are a
lot of of good people that are making
inroads that have been elected that that
are
uh making decisions based on the the
right things and not that videotape
coming out of that trip you made last
week or how much money they're gonna get
or
um things like that they're working for
their you know the treasure here on
Earth you think there are people that
are have actually good intentions and
are bought off I think so sure somebody
like Marjory Taylor green I think you
know Thomas Massey yeah sure I mean I
think too they came Marjorie already had
a successful business when she ran I
think Thomas also I don't think Thomas
Massey is rich okay I don't know what
his system yeah he's a MIT he built the
the cluck capacitor that's a chicken
thing an inventor my friend has one of
those in New Hampshire Jane you and he's
an awesome human being he built he
builds cluck capacitors they're
incredible it's I I said this before on
the show I talked to Thomas Massey after
he was on the show last time he was like
dude Congress is it's like a I don't
know how he exactly described it he's
like it's like a fraternity it's like a
not a fraternity but like it's like high
school like people emotionally yelling
and like I'm not gonna talk to that
[ __ ] you know like that kind of stuff
and he's like an engineer scientist and
is like we this is insane we need more
science we need more engineering yeah
and he's just like wow but you know you
do it anyway because you know you're
called to it okay for whatever reason
but let me ask you guys this on a scale
of one to ten how excited are you that
Trudeau is not our leader we have the
story from the Daily Mail president XI
humiliates Trudeau as he is caught on
camera tearing strips off Canadian PM
that their conversation the G20 has been
leaked to the papers it's not
appropriate this was the the most epic
cringe I've seen and and let's be real
so in this video Trudeau is trying to
talk to Xi Jinping cameras pop up and
man Trudeau looks weak it looks like a
mouse staring at an elephant Xi Jinping
won't even look at his face That's how
little respect he's giving him well I
get it Canada's a small nation XI
jinping's probably like why is this guy
thinking he can talk to me but talk
about humiliating I know did you guys
see this one yeah it's uh definitely an
example of a language barrier poor
Trudeau the poor guy I mean he he
probably had his socks ruffled from this
interaction that's probably the most
confrontation he got in his entire life
and this is sad for him mainly because
he loves China he talked about how he
adored China being able to change the
economy on the dime he he he adores what
China is doing and is replicating those
same policies inside of Canada of course
imprisoning his protesters debanking
people who dares be speak out against
him disarming the local population there
and now of course offering euthanasia to
of course the poor people there and the
depressed people there who does that
what kind of political leader does that
despotic leaders and when he was looking
to see his his his his his
beautiful Overlord that he wants to
replicate all of the policies he just
got smacked down right in the face and
it was it was incredible to see the body
language there because it said a lot and
when she told him off you see you see
Judo be like I hope you have peaceful
rational discussions in the future and
and then and then G's like what and then
he walks off like like Forrest Gump it
was pathetic it was sad and it shows you
how weak a lot of these individuals are
that do create the bad times that we
have to live through it's kind of like
when someone raises a pet alligator some
people are like I'm gonna have the most
dangerous animals pet and then one day
the animal grows up and bites him in the
leg and like and they have to euthanize
the animal and you just see that like
the disbelief and sadness in the owner's
face like this can't happen guys
ate that woman's face yeah this I feel
really bad for Trudeau I do I I feel a
deep sadness it reminds me of that time
that uh I don't I don't know if this
story is true because I'm having trouble
finding Source on it but it's a Elon
Musk was asked about Neil Armstrong
criticizing him and Elon cried because
you know Elon really looked up to Neil
Armstrong had this dream of of expanding
the space program and all that stuff and
to hear you know that one of your Heroes
was mocking or criticizing you must be
so brutal for Trudeau to finally get to
meet his hero only to be just poo pooed
and shoot aside must have been truly
devastating for the man absolutely what
was it exactly that happened that caused
this conversation did you guys hear like
something leaked so zoo was mad because
they were supposed to be having private
conversations between them the topics of
those conversation was leaked to the
Canadian press obviously from Trudeau
who didn't keep his word and and
promised to keep conversations secret
and private between the two so this is
also something that Emmanuel macron did
to Vladimir Putin Vladimir Putin was
also mad at him because I'm Manuel
macron had a documentary film crew
recording some of the conversations that
they thought was Private that they
thought wasn't going to be discussed to
the general public and they were talking
very frankly and this shows you that
Trudeau wasn't a man of his word wasn't
a man of Honor because they agreed hey
what we say here stays between us it
didn't it was leaked to the media by
Trudeau and then Trudeau is like Trudeau
leaked it uh someone in in the Trudeau
Administration if not Trudeau himself I
mean xinji ping was like yeah it's not
cool I'm paraphrasing I was like yeah
that's not cool dude and then Trudeau
was like we like to have open dialogue
and make sure and XI Jim who's like
buzz on it like just turns and like
walks up like what is he talking about
open dialogue that's not a concept that
I'm familiar with no I just want someone
should take that that interview of Elon
Musk crying and deep fake Trudeau's face
on it and then have the interviewer ask
the question like you met your hero Xi
Jinping and he was critical of your your
efforts how does that make you feel and
he's just like
he really he really cried huh Elon yeah
so that's the story that I read I
remember seeing it a while ago I mean I
actually I feel for Elon in that regard
it was I guess the story was back in uh
uh you know at the beginning of SpaceX
Neil Armstrong was critical of Elon
musk's attempt at a private space uh uh
business and then at some time later
after Elon Armstrong died Elon was asked
about it and Elon apparently a big hero
of his was Neil Armstrong I mean that's
real that's kind of sad absolutely a
little sad I know me too like that's a
big bummer imagine like being a little
kid and seeing something so profound as
a moon landing and space travel and
saying when I grow up I'm Gonna Change
the World and like you look at what
elon's doing now with SpaceX and how
powerful and amazing it is and uh Neil
Armstrong's never going to see that
because he died in 20 10 years ago but
but leaving this world critical of of
Elon that's gotta hurt man yeah you know
so I can understand how Trudeau feels
you know being shunned like this can you
imagine the boot licking that Trudeau is
going to have to do now to get into the
good graces of the Chinese or maybe
maybe he'll snap back oh yeah the other
night um Donald Trump this is last night
referred to Xi Jinping as the king of
China yeah King for life and XI was like
I'm not the king he's like well you have
all the power you're in for life so
basically King he's actually a Viceroy
this is when the emperor would designate
someone to become a king for Life
they're actually the Viceroy they don't
have familial
um they can't they can't pass the land
onto their kids upon death yes upon
death it goes back to the Empire and
then the emperor can designate another
viceroidal leaders but there's no
Emperor well there's the CCP is the
party is in control and there's probably
one of them there's a bunch of oligarchs
I think sure sure I think I think I like
Viceroy I wonder if there's a better
word though because the emperor would
determine the Viceroy the vicero would
die and then to choose someone else or
not or they would take away right right
so it doesn't have to be if a family
thing to correct anybody
if there's no Emperor no secession rules
with viceroys if there's no Emperor we
could say Viceroy but maybe there's a
better word for it I just don't know I
mean maybe there's a better word to
describe it's it's not King but you know
Viceroy Viceroy she
yeah it's better than president the
thing about presidents we talked with
the I think I can't remember who we had
on we had we had some China experts and
they said president is the wrong word uh
chairman might be the correct word right
yeah but then all of a sudden the media
started calling him president for some
reason yeah because they're trying to
normalize it make it seem like they're
trying to equate what he is to our
president who's elected I heard that
they changed the definition of the word
president in China to make it so that
what he was and I don't want to get this
wrong did you hear anything about this
wait did you say Sith Lord yes they
changed the definition of Sith Lord they
changed the definition of something this
is what I heard about six years ago so
that he could now be literally called
the president and it made sense whereas
like 30 years ago the word meant
something else yeah yeah so so just to
be clear in 2013 Trudeau said that he
most admires China when asked
specifically which country he admires he
said quote there's a level of admiration
I actually have for China because their
basic dictatorship is allowing them to
actually turn their economy around on a
dime and say we need to go green we need
to start you know investing in solar and
then he went on and of course saying
there is flexibility that I know Prime
Minister Stephen Harper who was prime
minister at the time quote must dream
about having a dictatorship where you
can do whatever you wanted that I find
quite interesting that's a direct quote
from Justin Trudeau remember 2013. and
then just about 10 years later he meets
his hero and it's disappointing yeah
he's probably balling his little fire
you get burned you know and this
happened publicly so you can imagine
what happens not publicly because you
could see Z in the translator the
translator even kind of moved out of the
way when the cameras were filming so
that he could get Trudeau's face in the
interaction that the translator was
aware of the camera he was like we need
this on tape we need the world to see
this so this is what's happening
publicly what's happening behind the
scenes when the cameras aren't there you
could only imagine how much more Brazen
how much more brutal these politicians
are to each other and I wouldn't be
surprised if she went up to to Trudeau
and just slapped him up a couple times
babe listen here boy you're gonna do as
I say and she's like yes sir yes I will
yes no problem and I I could actually
see that happening again that's not my
own Theory I could be wrong I want to do
a Winnie the Pooh joke but I don't know
how many people know the Winnie the Pooh
meme about Xi Jinping so I think they
actually pulled what people thought that
he looked like Winnie the Pooh and there
were names of it and then in China I
think they banned Winnie the Pooh
because yeah right yeah yeah and any
mention of it on WeChat and any photos
wow so much yeah yeah that's the thing
he's he looks happy oh Xi Jinping
actually looks like a really happy
friendly guy when I see his face like I
could laugh it up with him he does he
does the most annoying thing about doing
segments on China is that when I'm when
I'm looking for uh photos of individuals
you can usually see a range of emotion
that uh represents part of the idea so
like if there's a story where it's like
you know Joe Biden
um says X and it's like an angry thing
you could find a picture of Joe Biden
like giving a finger wave with Xi
Jinping it's like Stone and yes Stone
Face on every context it's just a
picture of him and he's just
just flat-faced like dude should play
poker I'd love to see him play Texas
Holdem I can't tell what he has Putin's
similar it's probably because he's like
xkgb it's like do not show any emotion
yeah your job is to hold all the cards
yeah just compartmental it just pushes
just keep it all in but you're right
you're right with Xi Jinping have you
seen the the Montage someone made where
it's all the different handshakes he's
given and the video is going through
every photo really really fast
and all the people are flickering and
changing and she is the exact same
position the whole time through like
hundreds of photos the way his body is
the way his face is the way his hand is
like never changes yeah it's a robot or
something well I bet they practice that
with something because I don't think Joe
Biden he might practice shaking people's
hands but I bet the ccp's choreographed
it like they have like meetings and like
you look at how to present yourself and
how to stand and how to be like
represent tallness sorry sorry quick
question people are saying Elon didn't
cry he almost cried he almost cried yeah
I want to say if he cried if he didn't
he teared up like Rachel Maddow when she
found out Trump didn't clue with Russia
what kind of person you know cheers on
and admires a Chinese dictatorship
a person like Bill Gates who also
admires the Chinese dictatorship who
previously just a couple months ago said
that they were doing a great job with
their zero sickness policy and of course
also does work business with the Chinese
government and uh also uh you know uh
what's it called what does he do
um Works officially uh the thing when
you give someone advice Consulting
Consulting yes sorry all right he
consults the CCP as well uh speaking of
Bill Gates uh I want to pull up this
tweet that I I have and credit goes to
Luke on this one actually I saw Luke
tweet this out so I actually went and
checked and it's true the world
government Summit 2022 that's what it's
called
has a video titled are we ready for a
new world order in it the host Becky
Anderson says are you ready for a new
world order
and this Channel World Government Summit
is verified by YouTube and YouTube added
a context fact check that says the New
World Order is a conspiracy theory which
hypothesizes a secretly emerging
totalitarian World Government they have
that tag on a video that is from the
verified Channel World Government Summit
you can't make this stuff up I'm sorry
many people are saying we're in a
simulation we're in a sitcom
yeah what is that duck call Double speak
where it's like you know you're holding
the booger this ain't a book I mean but
it's a book but it's not a book all
right it's the book but it's but it's
not that's so good yeah two plus two
equals five accept your reality as we
tell you it is don't you dare question
it we're building a new world order but
we're not building a new world order
because if you say we're building a new
world over there you're going to get
punished and screwed and demonetized and
downranked in the algorithm wait wait
and we're gonna make sure no one sees
your videos fact check fact check I have
to apologize correction everyone I now
recognize why I'm so wrong about this
the context provided says a conspiracy
theory which hypothesizes a secretly
emerging totalitarian World Government
this is overt stated and in your face
not a secret it's a different New World
Order the one public facing one well no
no quite simply put the conspiracy
theories that they're trying to keep it
a secret no they're straight up telling
you they're doing it yeah yeah I think
it's funny I was there I almost tweeted
at you last night I don't normally tweet
right at you guys but like uh that I
think that what's happening is the
global economic system is like in order
to avoid world war three this is like
through cities trap we're gonna just
transition the new world superpower to
become China and then so now they're
moving they're corrupting our economy
they printed us out of a bunch of money
they really I think people really don't
understand stand or care about the
American Constitution that aren't from
here like free speech is like dude I'm a
I'm a corporate executive I don't you
don't have free speech my Corporation
and if we're going to run the world like
a corporation if we have order you know
we need to stamp down on some of these
people that are thinking too freely
um and then there was more of the Tweet
I'll come up with it later but it's uh I
just how do we get to this point you
know for the longest time they said New
World orders a conspiracy theory there
was that Meme uh Sheamus over at Freedom
Tunes he did a meme correction but it's
hilarious where he's talking about the
reverse pyramid of conspiracies and at
the top in like their anti-semitic I
think it's in the anti-semitic point of
no return section this leftist wrote New
World Order is is in this conspiracy
theory bracket and I'm just like yo they
actually have the world government
Summit they're telling you they're doing
it they're not hiding it I think it's
when Rockefeller and his buddies it's
not a theory yeah they started the
Federal Reserve in 1913 on Jekyll Island
they they basically were trying to run
the world they didn't ever want to get
their companies broke up again like
Standard Oil was by the US government
they're like we're done with this
government crap and then we had a chance
to be like federal reserves busted we're
not using it anymore like 2007 Ron Paul
was like hey everyone everyone in the
world focus on this and we kind of did
but then that was our moment to be like
all right we're done with it we don't
need it anymore people might have got
killed but we don't need it anymore and
uh we didn't we didn't do it we just sat
around played video at least I just sat
around played video games I was a
assassinated if I spoke up silly me so I
just keep my mouth shut and now I'm
facing this
so we have to speak up
yeah I think the great reset equals the
apocalypse I think when people think
about the end of the world or when they
think about the apocalypse they think
about this great big explosion then
everybody's gone and certainly perhaps I
mean that that could be an outcome
but I think that the great reset for us
equals the apocalypse it's this ushering
in of what we're seeing as as evil this
is we're not building anything we're
destroying something or they're
destroying something
to rebuild something that we don't
recognize this post-modern this very
pagan
you know this whole world sort of thing
this new system
um and
I I I I also you know you think about
again like the Islamic religion where
where the apocalypse has to come in
order for their savior to come back
I think so it is true for Christianity
too right like there there are cultists
yes absolutely they're trying to invoke
Revelation absolutely sure in in some
corners of Christianity yes you want to
sort of root for the apocalypse for for
this for our savior to come back
um but it just everything Trends towards
destruction we're not building anything
we're not
uh you know we were just talking about
Trudeau and and and what was in the news
today about
um I forget what the acronym for it is
is like government assisted assisted
death or something maybe yeah right what
is that what what is that are you
medically assisted something dying yeah
induced death or something like that
it's and it's it's a it's an awful awful
thing
um medical assistance in dying yeah like
that's that's the that's the solution
like there we go there's people who are
in there pain people who are Canada's
doing this I think and there there are
people posting on like Tumblr and forums
saying as soon as I'm 18 I'm getting it
right away yeah yeah the Pod just shows
up at your house I'm a man Bender you
walk in with the coin and yeah suicide
Booth the New World Order it's not a
conspiracy it's something that we're
going through right now it's a buzzword
used by many powerful people as a way to
try to centralize more power money and
Authority for themselves it's been
talked about for a very long time
predominantly from the David
Rockefellers of the world and other very
powerful individuals David Rockefeller
in his own autobiography by the way said
quote this is his own words in his own
book that I actually confronted him with
one-on-one face to face he said quote
some even believe we the Rockefeller
family are a part of a secret cabal
working against the best interest of the
United States characterizing my family
and me as internationalist and
conspiring with others around the world
to build a more integrated Global
political and economic structure one
world if you will if that's the charge I
stand guilty and I am proud of it David
filler his own autobiography I asked him
about it I went I went up face to face
and I was like you still believe in this
let's let's talk about this he of course
you know freaked out and I assume he
said yes but but it was nice comments
there's many of these comments
throughout history but but so let me ask
this why is it that Rockefeller writes
that in his book that George George it
was H.W bush said we make many we're
beginning to see a new world order and
they're specifically saying a world
order and a new one there's the liberal
economic order and they're talking about
launching a new one this is overt I
think the Council on Foreign Relations
was it uh the website has it discussing
a liberal economic order why then does
the media YouTube Wikipedia all come on
say it's a lie and a conspiracy when
they're telling us they're doing it I
think it's because that there that
people are afraid we will establish a
new world order with American
constitutionalism and that could be
upending klaus's dream like we have a
basically the liberal economic order is
is over it's done it's ending we need to
pull a George Washington uh socially
where we say we give the power away we
give it back to the people because we
trust the world and we trust Humanity to
answer your question Tim it's to
demoralize people it's to show them that
we're going to overtly have these plans
we're going to talk about them but you
can't talk about them because we're more
powerful than you are and this is a part
of the larger kind of psyops that's
being played here with this this these
mind games this is essentially in mind
game saying I could do what I want I
could say what I want you can't that
right there is showing the true power of
what the new world order is in its
Essence this kind of larger hypocrisy
and abuse of power as they're using it
to gain more power for themselves I want
to I want to stress this point do not
think of the phrase new world order as a
proper noun at and that's what a lot of
people do they think of new world order
as like a proper noun no no no it is
break each word down to their root
meanings and that's actually what the
phrase is there is the liberal world
order or liberal economic order Ian's
brought it up many many times we've
pulled it up the website from I think I
think it's CFR is that the who the
console inform relations yeah and
there's also the trilateral commission
and the Bilderberg Group they're all
coalesce with each other and they all
talk about the same right building a new
world order and they have websites
published on this News Guard certified
and when they say New World Order what
they're saying is we're currently in the
liberal World Order now we need a new
version of the liberal world order a
world order that is new the new world
order doesn't specifically refer to
anything other than they want a global
system of control it is not it's not a
secret they've said it over and over and
over again perhaps they're arguing the
conspiracies that people believe weird
things about it I don't know whatever
but they're doing it and they're having
some it's called the world government
Summit it's verified by YouTube
yeah so there you go and it's at the end
of the day what they're calling for is
more centralization more bureaucracy
more power being held in fewer hands
which of course is always ripe for abuse
whenever we have a fewer and fewer
individuals of of more people of more
land uh of more uh things that they
could conquer in subject this is
essentially a form of domination and
that's exactly why there's so much Mind
Games to this where you can't talk about
this but they can you know we need
freedom and I think part of this Mad
Dash towards Global governance is
because Antarctica is about to become
melted and a big giant continent that
people are going to try and colonize and
when they do there will be a global war
that's that China and America and Russia
all trying to take it at once it could
destroy the Earth maybe they're trying
to say no only one of you is going to
get it but I think before before uh
Antarctica becomes available for for
player uh use the the last update patch
in the simulation has to occur so that's
the final story which is going to be
probably Trump three three Trump three
the you know A New Hope or whatever you
want to call it and then then we're
gonna get the the expansion pack Earth
simulation two the Antarctic campaign
well you can only rent the expansion
pack you never actually own it yeah
that's what you're like you'll license
it and then you can create new
characters starting in the and
Antarctica content really excited for
this plus the new skill sets that are
being released I hear that journalists
will get the ability to communicate via
neural Link in the latest expansion I
like Freedom man I don't like the idea
that cops are on the street corners
watching you whenever you walk around I
don't want it if you don't want it then
join me now imagine the crazy crazy
Insanity that you'll have to deal with
when everything's online then they have
control of what you see and what you say
and what they don't say and what they do
to you and what you can you call out and
can't call out but as you said Tim yeah
the CFR website officially says Global
we're calling for Global governance and
they have an article on their website
what is the liberal World Order and they
go on and explain hey we need everything
in the hands of all these private uh
International corporations and Banks and
we need less representation we need less
people being able to decide their own
lives and we need that decided by
Central controllers I always I always
like pulling up this article from
world101.cfr.org what is the liberal
World Order because it is News Guard
certified 100 out of 100 and it's like
how do you get that rating and
especially like the CFR they're not a
news organization why are they rated 100
out of 100 sure whatever but liberal
world order it's on their website they
say after World War II the delicious
conflicting Ministry countries sought to
ensure the world never again would
devolve into horrific violence blah blah
blah here's why we did it here's what
we're doing so when they say we want a
new world order the saying to advance
beyond their old liberal World Order
where did that article come out because
it sounds like something I wrote
they've been talking about it for a very
long time ever since big nearbyzinski
and David Rockefeller helped fund and
and start uh the Council on Foreign
Relations and there are quasi-private
not private club they have some public
meetings but in private they also have
big members of the corporate media they
have a lot of politicians even weird
politicians like Tulsi gabbard and other
of course Mainline big politicians that
are a part of their meetings they meet
in secret and also talk about and decide
policy openly and and uh and secretly
let's let's jump to this uh next story
actually and Luke I want to throw this
one to you if you want to want to talk
about this yeah I mean this is a little
bit more I mean this is the story I
don't even know where to begin let me
get through a lot of emotions here but
so uh Vladimir zielinski of Ukraine
claimed Russian missiles hit Poland and
then immediately started ramping up
calling for for a reciprocation calling
for more Aid and more military directly
blaming Russia before too much was known
now you know Fair Point this was AP
reporting it because the U.S official
said so
for a world leader to then call for an
escalation of war and trying Jackson in
World War III is horrifying now we even
have NATO countries saying like yo this
dude's kind of losing it so maybe it
won't be a new world order maybe it will
be Ukraine sparking World War III our
foolishness NATO joining in the fight
getting into a war with Russia nukes get
fired but uh some people have pointed
something out interesting so some
missiles hit Poland right initially it
was reported that they were Russian
everybody losing their minds some people
said it was a false flag some people are
now saying it was a false flag done so
poorly that not even NATO could pretend
it was actually Russian missiles but if
it was Ukrainian missiles that struck
Poland then do we call do we do we
invoke Article 5 against Ukraine I
thought that too yeah it's up to Poland
I guess Poland's like we declare war on
Ukraine good let's stop giving him money
at the very least yeah I mean it's this
is just such a crazy situation that
could have escalated so fast and thank
goodness it it didn't I mean I'm from
Poland I love my country I don't want to
see War it's already horrible that
there's war in Ukraine that so many
people have to suffer through this
nonsense and to have people try to
escalate this conflict trying to get
other countries involved in this
conflict trying to expand this proxy war
between the East and the West is
extremely Reckless it's extremely
dangerous there's an article that I just
tweeted on on my Twitter page uh from
the Independent talking about how
zielinski is certain that this blast in
Poland came from a Russian enemy
missiles again no one was certain no one
knew what was going on here uh but of
course the corporate media didn't wait
MSNBC was talking about retaliation
immediately I have an article here here
pulled up by the daily mail saying the
West plots their response against Russia
and again we don't know exactly what
happened here as right now the president
of the United States the president of
Poland the head of NATO are coming out
and saying it actually wasn't a Russian
missile it was most likely a missile
that was provided to Ukraine by the West
in order to act like a defense system
that could have accidentally or
purposefully depending what you believe
here could have been a potential false
thought I could have not been a flag
could have been a real legit accident
here but with zelinski's comments here
it really makes you wonder because they
were aggressive they were hyperbolic and
they're extremely dangerous not only to
the people of Ukraine but the people of
Poland the people of the world and this
situation is reckless and needs to stop
immediately we have this article from
The Daily Mail zelenski insists missile
that hit Poland was Russian despite NATO
U.S and even Polish president saying it
was a Ukrainian air defense misfire but
all agree Putin to blame for nearly
sparking World War III oh how about that
huh well yeah again Putin did start the
war and we have to understand here his
major calling card throughout all of
this is like it's him specific
specifically saying there's going to be
a new world order we want Russia to be a
part of this new world order so that's
one of his major stances that he's
always been making as he's been calling
out the West here but this proxy war is
again Reckless stupid dangerous and and
the corporate media organizations that
spread fake news automatically after
this didn't offer any retractions didn't
have any edit statements didn't have any
corrections on their articles the AP
literally just changed their article
from Russia attacks Poland to to just to
something else I'm I'm some icing here
I'm not exactly saying the exact titles
here but you get the drift of what I'm
trying to say here they were normally
spreading dangerous fake news that could
have started a global war and I disagree
they were knowingly doing it they were
when you don't know what happened you
can't automatically jump to conclusion
then state it as fact when the stakes
are as high as they are exactly yeah and
that's exactly what they did they say
automatically this is it we don't know
what happened here and you see how
thirsty these are these people are for a
global conflict which should be
prevented at all costs here another
thing to really consider here is the
fact that you know governments and
militaries make mistakes all the time
and it could just be a dumb Soldier it
could be an accident it could be a
miscalculation and boom we have World
War III this is why this conflict needs
to be de-escalated needs to be stopped
people need to come to the table sit
down and negotiate a peace deal
immediately now it it before it's too
late I agree I agree that
again the stakes really are so high with
all of this and it's become just sort of
passive like well something else
happened today you know it's just a
headline but meanwhile
literally the whole world is at stake
the the with nuclear war and it's and
it's right on our doorstep
um and again as I was saying before
about
about this trend towards destroying
everything why why aren't we trying
why aren't we investing 60 billion
dollars whatever it is in peacekeeping
efforts or trying to keep the peace and
just stopping all this whoever's dying
on on both sides it's just awful again
it's the energy that's being created
there is sadness and destruction and and
just awfulness that that projects out
into the world and and Beyond in a
different realm and it just it makes
everything sour and and and leads us
towards bad I wish it were as easy as to
just say you know we shouldn't have War
but the challenge I guess is when you
see some of the things that we've seen
with
um Isis for instance and they're not
stopping and they're expanding and the
caliphate was growing and growing and
growing at a certain point it's like you
can cross your fingers and over peace
all you want but dangerous people
start pushing and doing crazy stuff now
I'm not arguing the U.S should have
intervened in the Middle East in the
first place I think U.S intervention
caused the rise of Isis but I used this
as an example of what do you do when you
see a country expand like China's
expanding dramatically in the South
China Sea we can we we can sit back and
just be like you know let's just keep
the peace and hope nothing happens but
they keep expanding the same thing is
true and look here's the issue NATO is
doing the exact same thing so I'm not
saying that any good guys here but if
you're trying to be Noble and honorable
and just say I'm going to do everything
I can to keep the peace but the person
across from you is just cheating lying
and stealing at a certain point it comes
to blows
um I understand that war is certainly a
part of our existence in this space and
in this realm
but I do not believe in this instance
that war is
could have been averted or it should be
averted I don't understand why everybody
uh our Administration our country leans
into these sort of things the anti-war
effort where is every where is everybody
that was so upset about war when it was
happening in Iraq and Afghanistan and
everyone was like yeah the Russians are
bad kill them all yeah right after the
Crimea annexation is when it kicked back
up all this anti-russians well so so
I'll give you the gist I suppose and
this is coming from somebody with no
clearance so I have no idea but I do
know that the U.S wants control of
Ukraine Western forces NATO because
Russia controls a large percentage
percentage of natural gas flowing into
Europe which means that the economy of
Europe is staggered by Russia so the U.S
basically wants to take control of
Ukraine control the valves of natural
gas into Europe and then put the
pressure back on Russia Russia refuses
this war happens
so I suppose
um you can argue NATO should not have
been expanding the way it was and we'd
avoid war and high gas prices is better
than War I think that's a part of it but
I think but we wouldn't have high gas
prices we would have lower gas prices if
we had just uh better relations with
other countries and more free trade in
the market Russia was charging a lot and
so Western forces tried to build a
pipeline through Syria through turkey
into Europe to compete with Russia but
Syria wouldn't allow it surprise
surprise Syria destabilizes how
fortunate and like the point is it's not
just about the cost of the gas it's
about how much energy are we getting so
they say the EU was formed explicitly to
unify Europe against the growing threat
of China and they need gas not not so
much just cheap but they need more so
that they can expand their economy grow
and be able to compete with a growing
Chinese economy Russia was causing
problems that regard because Russia
tacitly works with China so the US was
like we're not going after China first
Russia is the weak Target and went after
them Donald Trump was right when he was
like China as the bigger threat and they
freak freak out because they're like
yeah but we want to go after Russia
first so look I don't like any of it I
don't think any of it's Justified I
think it's a bunch of paranoia and and I
understand the arguments people make
about the fear of a uni of a multi-polar
world where you could potentially get
World War III but this is what it boils
down to the liberal World Order people
do not want Russia and China to gain
enough power to compete with their new
world order their liberal World Order
because they fear world war three would
happen if that was the case so they'll
will do they will do everything they can
to dominate and Crush their opponents by
any means to maintain dominance because
they think if we're not in charge War
happens this is what gets me though the
liberal economic order the best thing
for that if they really want that to
succeed is to have an alliance with
Russia Russia is in the center of the
world essentially if you're looking at
China and the United States and Europe
and all that Russia is right there
whichever side Russia goes to is going
to gain a 90 60 more like they're gonna
gain so much power there's so much land
that's hard to travel that is like if
you have can put troops in Russia you're
good to go on a conflict so why would
they antagonize if the liberal so that
makes me think of the GDP of Italy okay
but they also people need to understand
the context here they control our own if
they shut off the oil like it's not just
about how much they're charging it's
about are they even gonna give it to you
at all but the more oil we have on the
market the cheaper the oil is now
deliberately denying the oil makes the
price of oil go up even more than it
automatically would even if Russia was
price hiking it they would still have to
compete with other markets but right now
the the price of oil has gone up so much
mainly because of this this proxy war
this proxy conflict what gets me is I
think that people are manipulating the
liberal economic order to to go to war
with Russia to lose its power and and so
that they can be like well see it didn't
work out kind of thing and there are
people in the liberal economic order
that are like they think they're doing
the right thing they think that they're
preserving democracy and and making
freedom but what's really happening is
they're antagonizing one of the
potentially greatest allies
all of this may be depressing so let me
uh get into the good news the good news
the white pill I want you all to feel
much better with this report CNN ahead
Chris Licht admits layoffs on the
horizon as anxious staffers Grill him
during Town Hall huge nerves oh no CNN's
going to be laying off more people guys
uh oh what's what's this story from
deadline Vice Media cuts around two
percent of digital news and Publishing
staff as part of latest consolidation
efforts that's what they call it
consolidation I call it the end of the
Old Guard Vice was supposed to be the IG
New Media but they went woke so fast Now
CNN is crumbling down and I want to
stress this as it pertains mostly to CNN
Donald Trump has announced he's running
for president
TNN has been brought to heal is in
shambles Twitter is under the control of
Elon Musk
it's going to be a Donald Trump rematch
but without the establishment cultural
Powers at the level they were in the
past several election Cycles so should
be interesting to say the least but um I
know Luke is the is the most sad about
CNN's laughs I know I need a violin here
to to reel in this moment here I can't
believe you know we can't have so much
great where else are we going to get the
memes from where else are we going to
get all the inspiration hold on there
that's actually true I know that you
weren't kidding we need the opposition
yeah if there's no CNN we need the hacks
we're not the hacks I mean what are we
going to do I guess I can make memes
about about Luke you can make me he'll
be the only one else in media yeah I'll
play the antagonistic idiot for you but
the narrative machine is breaking at a
time when when we're going to see Donald
Trump come back the The Narrative
machine is going full swing they're
saying he's a drag on the party he's not
they're saying there was no Red Wave
there was and they're they're trying to
to blame Donald Trump and say he's got
to go when in reality what happens is
Media manipulation and ballot harvesting
the reason and I'll stress this point
too there was a Red Wave five million
more Republican votes than Democrat
votes sorry that's just a reality just
because it wasn't in the right places
doesn't mean that there was no Red Wave
but I get it if you're arguing Red Wave
meant a wave of Victories across the
country agreed if you're arguing that
Republicans turned out in massive
numbers then they did it just didn't hit
the places that mattered most did you
see how the New York Post covered
Trump's announcement uh-huh they put it
on page 26 and their title was Florida
man makes announcement that's how they
covered they're all terrified of this
man they're saying look at the same time
the New York Post New York Post I mean
they're the ones that broke the hunter
Biden story sure sure but at the same
time that these media Outlets are
claiming Donald Trump is done and it's
over they're also claiming it's a
dangerous insurrectionist who must be
stopped at all costs
we get it I see you they're terrified
and they're just they're that here's
what happened the first time around
CNN and these other woke Outlets went
for the Trump is evil Trump is evil
everybody stop stop stop
well all that did was embolden Trump now
they're trying to play it cool Trump
he's so six years ago he's not cool you
like Trump here's all I am that's not
gonna work either when Trump gets on
stage and then starts going after these
people calling them out people are gonna
laugh at it I think that even though we
see CNN MSNBC these different Outlets
sort of sizing down
uh even as long as they can still get
their message out and there's no or
there's little competition against that
message then then mission accomplished
because they can put out a narrative
they can put out a story or they can put
out some sort of Spin and then go on all
the socials where there's a lot of
conservatives and people that are no
longer allowed to voice back and so
therefore their narrative their lies
their or their truth depending on how
you look at it is able to take root in
that way and you know I don't see these
like CNN actually making a pivot towards
let's actually
um tell the truth I mean maybe now every
now and again just for just just for fun
they they will or maybe just water it
down so it's kind of like Fox News where
you're kind of thinking you're watching
the right you know the the the the the
actual news but you're not yeah yeah
it's going to be interesting I just want
to make a really quick point because uh
there is some uh rumors that that CNN
viewership did go up during the Trump
announcement and if you look at CNN's
viewership it's pretty much reliant on
Donald Trump so now will the corporate
media get a Revival from Trump or will
ignore him how will this play out I
don't know two million 430
000 views
CNN as compared to 5 million one hundred
fifty seven thousand on Fox as compared
for last night yeah for the Trump these
are last night ratings yes one million
127
000 for Newsmax and this is CNN's owned
by Warner Brothers Discovery so it's I
think at this point which is owned by
BlackRock State Street you know
International marketing firms and
investment firms and I think that
they're using it as like a form of
impact investment at this point the CNN
news brand they're just going to use it
to to spread their ideology and uh let
the company be damned like they'll let
it go under and dissipate they got
bought out you know I don't know when
uh 12. this year Warner Brothers bought
them this year this is going to be
interesting do you see Trump giving a
Revival to the media press one in the
chat press two if you if you don't see
that happening because I'm curious what
the people think out there
because I I don't know it could go
either way here
so this is uh was it last night
CNN had a total of 2.43 million viewers
at 9 pm and it had 5.157 Wagner on MSNBC
had 1.8 uh so let's do this let's go
back
and then we'll take a look at uh if
adweek loads I don't know the website
never loads Monday to see what their
ratings are maybe it won't won't
actually allow us to see it we'll see
what happens but I'd love to compare
there's a lot of ones in the chat a lot
of people take a look at this the the
the views were double the day before
um the views were half for Hannity and
for uh
for for CNN so
I I have a feeling that CNN is going to
lean back into Trump stuff but I don't
know if if uh ratings is what's going to
sell for them I think that they're using
it as impact investment they're they're
looking at it as a loss they don't want
money out of it they just want to change
people's minds to get them to support
the New World Order so just really
quickly when uh the news came about that
missile strike in Poland I automatically
had social media up but just to be just
to be aware of everything I was like let
me just turn on the TV see what they're
saying and I went on Fox and on Fox
during this key important breaking news
moment they had an anchor celebrating
his own birthday talking about his
achievements wow right I went on MSNBC
and they were talking about we need
retribution we need to act right now and
then I went on went on to CNN and they
were talking about can can you guess
Donald Trump in January 6th during this
key moment and they weren't breaking the
news they weren't talking about what was
happening in Ukraine in Europe with
Russia with this larger War at the G20
they were talking about Trump and
January 6th uh and I was like really
this this is this is what I'm tuning
into this is insane I get more reliable
news on Twitter than I do of course the
corporate media I'm also looking at
these layoffs and that I I've been
noticing the last week Amazon is about
to lay off ten thousand employees and
that'll laid off 11 11 000 Twitter laid
off half their staff which is a slightly
different situation well it's it's a
shrinkage of the economy right now
because of what we did with for the
covid money print scam or scheme
whatever you want to call it
um and now we're starting to see like 10
000 people what in the heck that's a lot
of uh there was a bunch of corporate
layoffs were you guys following all
these corporate layoffs in the last over
the last week well I mean CNN and vice
CNN voice is there Amazon I'm trying to
get a list of a meta oh you know what I
really want to know about this is a
little off topic but Larry and Sergey
the guys that created Google and now
alphabet where are they what are they
doing they are in control of the world's
largest media apparatus ever created and
they were supposedly a free speech
Advocates but are they just gone full
technocrat like where are they full type
no cred probably living on an island
somewhere in the largest giant mansion
ever created with the smart home and
they're just like whatever I like to
imagine that the rich people built the
city underwater called Rapture and
they're all experimenting with uh Gene
editing technology you guys you bought
YouTube manual yeah but Ian they've been
down in this underwater city for so long
and the gene splicing has mutated people
and the society collapsed so they're
living in this is not a video game
that Bioshock is one of the best games
ever
yeah that's a video game but yeah it's
the general idea is um Galt Gulch
the powerful Elites basically leave
let's let the system rot because it's
gone astray and people want stupid
things and then the people who are
productive dip out I don't blame them
this is what we're this is idiocracy we
you know we talked about this the other
day when we talked about the Exodus from
cities think about all of the people who
fled New York or California because of
the coveted policies or whatever that's
a brain drain on these places the most
productive people are moving to Texas in
Florida Joe Rogan Elon Musk Texas so
they're going to bring all of that
Enterprise and Ingenuity into these
other states the economy of those States
is going to Skyrocket it's going to
create this new I don't know I don't
know what you'd call it but um
effectively like a a business rush
there's going to be new opportunities
new money new inventions new tech and
these other blue states are going to
turn into wastelands they've lost their
their top talent where are you Michael
and where do you see things going
financially as well
well obviously there's a massive
um
contraction happening
um I was just out for the past month and
a half all across the country
um all over really
um
and and and you see it everywhere the
the the hurt the the economic hurt
whether it's gas prices or people just
going to the supermarkets
um
I don't see us going in a good
uh Direction economically
because of the system and because of
what we're not doing
um as well as the things that we're
doing I don't have a positive outlook on
on the economy unless and I know that
that's what we everybody's trying to do
is get people into these positions of
power that can then create a system and
make the changes that we need to make so
that the economy does work for everyone
because I think the way to peace and
prosperity and and happiness and joy and
good things are is when people are happy
and productive and they're doing things
and you know pursuing happiness pursuing
the things that they want to pursue when
you have people that are trying to
figure out how am I going to feed my
kids how am I going to keep the lights
on it's going to get cold in the winter
wonder how I'm gonna heat my house that
really takes away from the things in in
life individually and and collectively
that then create a society where we can
start to gain those levels in the
simulation and and get higher up in this
instead of
everything burning up and breaking down
let's talk about the cultural stuff so
so watching CNN and these other outlets
Fall Apart
uh is good because they're narrative
machines but one of the most important
things that's often overlooked by the
right conservatives Libertarians or
whatever is creating culture that
inspires young people so right now with
you here we have a lot of people
chatting how they're huge fans of the
Misfits but you're also here challenging
The Establishment I'm curious your
thoughts on how do we create an
anti-establishment uh cultural apparatus
and more importantly how is it that so
many anti-establishment musicians just
flipped and went full pro-war Pro
lockdown that blew my mind how that how
did that happen well I think that and
it's not just because I'm here I think
that you and and your team and everybody
here is the perfect example of what
needs to be built for this parallel
economy or these parallel structures
that will push uh that will build what
what needs to be built not only do you
do this sort of thing and have
conversations about all of this but
you're so you're you're creating shows
and music and entertainment all these
different things
um and intention has a lot to do with
that your energy and where where your
perspectives and your your your friends
and your um your colleagues where
they're coming from they're coming from
a good place and so that resonates
um
you know so I think that that's that's
that's a good thing when we we see these
CNN or MSNBC when we see the viewership
going down and these companies starting
to shrink in size that's a good thing
because we can fill that vacuum or we
need to fill that vacuum with these
things out that we're building well so
so one of the reasons
we here at timcast.com become a member
are focusing on cultural Investments
like pop culture crisis is a show very
similar to this format hosted by Brett
dasovich and Mary Morgan but it's pop
culture because we were like not
everybody likes politics we want to
create a show where we can build
influence in other areas Tales from the
inverted world is Honduras Thompson
meets The X-Files and of course we're
doing music we've got some skateboarding
and rollerblading and scooting plans
we're doing this though mostly because
I'm looking at you know like some of the
bands that I grew up listening to that
were basically saying F the machine are
now saying yay the machine yes like how
did that happen
well I think a lot of that comes with
ignorance I think a lot of that also
comes with
um people like us and I hate saying that
but but people that
um
it takes a certain person to say maybe
I'm wrong
like I'm going to take this position
about whatever maybe I'm wrong let me go
see if I'm wrong and then spend time
finding out if you're wrong and and
recalibrating your position if it needs
to be because doing that you gain
knowledge you you're able to articulate
your position you know what you know and
why you know it
um and not just well you know because
gender queer book told me that and so
therefore that's the way that I feel
but in order to do that I think that
there's certain you know morals and
integrity that that needs to be built
into someone and that goes into a whole
conversation about parenting and and
everything but you know with the with
the musicians in in the entertainment
industry I think a lot of it certainly
is ignorance but also I think that
there's some people that perhaps they
might or I know I know that there's some
people out there that know what the
truth is and know what is kind of going
on
but there's there's there's fear and
there's selfishness involved in it
because they don't want to lose anything
they don't want to lose their contract
they don't want to lose they don't want
people saying bad things about them on
their Facebook oh God forbid they lose
their Facebook what would they do oh my
God and so and so they just go along to
get along uh regardless of of what their
heart is is saying you know the
Believers believe you know when you have
the holy spirit inside you and you have
that discernment that at some point if
you continue if you just keep rejecting
that your heart hardens and then you
don't hear that anymore and so you're
able to just go full on
um to you know any any port you you want
um and so there's a lot there's a lot of
that in the entertainment industry
there's a lot of that in the in in the
music industry because everybody wants
to be popular and loved and be that
person and have the lights on them
that's what it's about and we'll take
any route they need to to get there and
hold on to it same thing in politicians
it's it's power you people you know you
you want that power it's difficult to
take a position and find yourself
completely alone like where do you feel
alone and if these bands
uh shout out to The Offspring for firing
their drummer because he was unable to
get vaccinated due to medical condition
if bands like that stood up and said
sorry guys all of our shows are being
canceled uh to all of our fans who spend
all this money we we are unfortunately
unable to do the show because the venues
won't allow our drummer in what do you
think would happen when 5 million ticket
holders call Ticketmaster all at the
same time Ticketmaster is going to be
like why is our system breaking down
they're going to contact the venues and
be like what are you doing why are these
shows getting canceled and they're gonna
say well we we told The Offspring they
weren't allowed to have their drummer in
the building what are you what we have a
contract well well the government passed
a law then everyone's going to start
calling up the local governments what
are you doing we got 5 million cancel
contracts are falling apart if one band
just said we will cancel every show
it would cause a chain reaction that
would make it all the way to the point
where large lobbyists and investors
would be standing at the desk of the
mayor of New York saying I will destroy
you politically unless you fix this
problem and they'll be like okay okay
we'll rescind this but no the whiny
pathetic establishment loses The
Offspring said uh how about we just fire
our drummer of 17 years when we we our
families have hung out together
screw them I'd rather make money and
fire him these people are [ __ ]
pathetic okay now I'm swearing no you're
right though I mean at least there was a
pathetic move I don't want to judge them
their personalities because I don't know
them but I I think it was a weak move if
anything they have so much power to
control culture I said this I've said
this about a lot of things I agree with
you I agree patreon they they they
banned this guy Robert Spencer he's an
Islamic scholar and he's controversial I
guess I'm not sure not Richard Spencer
Robert Spencer different guy and the
reason was if we don't MasterCard made
us do it if we didn't ban him then we'd
have to shut the whole site down and I'm
like I dare you yeah to I did MasterCard
I dare you to have the hundred million
plus subscriptions on the site disappear
and have each and every one of those
people calling you on the phone asking
you why you did it but no one has the
balls to actually be like I'll go for it
let's see what happens there were some
performers that would refuse uh to play
I think did they Chappelle do that was
he like I'm not performing if you're
going to have a vax mandate was he one
of those guys uh I know Chrissy Mayer
wouldn't wouldn't perform well not that
she's at Dave Chappelle's Fame yet but I
think I think Crowder and Ruben were
explicit I'm not sure uh they said they
moved venues I think it was Reuben
specifically was like we won't do a show
here and move down I'm not sure maybe it
wasn't Reuben yeah but um look I like
Joe Rogan but even he said here's what
we'll do I'll give you a refund if you
didn't want if you didn't know that they
were doing these rules and perhaps the
argument is that there were contracts
that locked Joe in and if he canceled it
could have caused him major damage or
something like that
but it's just like but that's that's the
I understand I understand that
there's a there's a lot at stake when
you take these positions however I I
agree with you that if some for like
Offspring or some of these larger acts I
mean I I didn't play The Whiskey A Go Go
for that reason because they had a
vaccine mandate in the city at the time
and I I said that I I didn't want to
play to a segregated audience nor did I
want someone to make a decision a
medical decision like that to come see
me that's crazy and so I just said I'm
not going to do it when things are
different I'll go back and I did I just
played there a couple weeks ago
um but I wish I had that power to you
know like The Offspring and some of
these other bands where if they just
stood up and said we already have so
much I know and there's and all of their
fans would not all of them but a lot of
the fans would get behind them or at
least say well what do you mean and then
you can have the larger conversation and
that would then put that pressure on the
record companies on the management
company on the lawyers on and all of the
the system that is the industry that
pushes back on these on these things let
me let me tell you let's go back to that
earlier segment where I was making fun
of Trudeau beating his hero and uh the
Elon Musk thing where he almost cried
died when told about Neil Armstrong the
first album I ever bought was Americana
by The Offspring the first tab book I
ever got was Americana by The Offspring
the second was ixnay on the Ombre by The
Offspring followed by the tab book for
X9 and the Ombre and then of course
there's ignition then then I said wow I
better go back even further I got their
smash was obvious right so you're a fan
yeah this was the first this was the
band that got me into music this was the
band that at the time all that was was
all we had was pop so whatever was on
the radio was what it was didn't know
anything I didn't even know the names of
these bands and then my friend said
listen to this and handed me an
Americana CD and I learned all the songs
and I still have in my playlist I love
all of their 90s stuff and some of their
2000 stuff and I even like a lot of
their later stuff and then what a
letdown for them to be at a point where
I think Dexter sold the catalog for like
30 million or whatever to be so rich you
want for nothing and then to look into
the eyes of someone who's been there for
you for 17 years yeah their drummer and
say get out because I'm old that's
that's the dirtiest most vile
inhuman and old man not only that they
could have actually just been like bro
they're not gonna let you in the
building I'm sorry but don't worry we
will get someone to play with us but
we're not gonna let you down you're good
and we'll we'll do Studio stuff with you
and that's still in my opinion not the
strongest thing they could have done no
but I'd still be like I get it I get it
you know the fans want to show you don't
want to let them down but you're not
going to leave someone hanging instead
they're just like later bro and and the
crazy thing about this whole story is
that Pete Parada is the drummer he's
awesome he's done work with us his
doctor was like I recommend against this
because of the the potential medical
condition you have that's right okay and
then they're like get out yeah it's dirt
and if you would have listened to them
he could have got seriously hurt or
could have died but they still wanted to
to force him to do that to stay in the
band that that is cruel that is
absolutely evil uh Jim Brewer I think
did it the right way whenever people
were discriminating against somebody
whenever a venue had a vax mandate and
were segregating people based on
government compliance he said no I'm not
going to be performing here I'm only
going to be performing at places that
don't discriminate against bodily
autonomy against individuals deciding
their own Pathways their own life so
shouts out to Jim Brewer he was a real
one we should get him on the show he
does incredible work and I love his work
anyway he's a funny guy
that guy's Jim you are awesome yeah
Jim's incredible shout out to Jim
because because as much as we criticize
these horrible people we gotta shout out
the good people and promote them and all
the good stuff that they do as well yeah
Brewer's tremendous he's got a great
heart he's a family man he's great and
and absolutely has has taken the the
right path in all this and and obviously
has a hilarious perspective on it that
he puts in his routines but
I you would think certainly that
somebody like Pete you know who played
with these guys came up with these guys
there's a Brotherhood when you're on
tour with somebody and you know you're
in a band like that
um maybe it was 14 years I don't know
was it 14 or 17 maybe it was 14. it's a
long that's a long long time not a big
difference it's a long time it's not
just being on tour it's not just the
tour thing and playing in a band
families and friends it's your whole
life it's your whole freaking world that
some and then all of a sudden it's just
well see you later dude dude you got to
look up Pete Parada on the internet at
the face the picture of his face he's
like it's awesome looking he's hitting
it's so hard he's on the drums I'm
trying to figure out when he joined the
offspring
face to face in 98 and then Offspring in
2007 so that'd be about 14 years ago 15
years ago
the guy's amazing 2007 yeah 15 okay I
was wrong yeah I was thinking like wait
a minute did I give him extra years
maybe it was 14. before that he's with
saves the days I couldn't I couldn't
believe that story when I heard it uh
because it because like my attitude is
if something happened like that and my
response was okay well we're going to
keep you know moving forward I wouldn't
terminate like if I had somebody was
working for me for six months I wouldn't
fire him I'd be like you're cool dude
we'll figure it out yeah it's crazy and
that's a scary thing the people that you
think have your back
in in the past couple of years at least
in my experience and I I've lost people
in my life that walked away from me that
I've known for decades you know 20 years
people that I was very very close to
that again because of the pressure
because of well I might lose my Facebook
and because you know I don't know you've
gone crazy or you know people that know
people that fell for the delusion that
believe the delusion
and the lies knowing me like knowing who
I am and and
knowing my heart but then saying yeah no
well we're gonna go with with with with
this
whole thing
um and we're gonna that's that's a
that's scary that's like you when you
hear stories about you know when the
Nazis rolled into some of these the
different cities where just overnight
you know the pogroms these people they
went to school together they were family
and then all of us they're dragging each
other into the streets and they're
ripping their clothes off and they're
beating them
that's that's where we're at it's almost
like we're practicing for it and it's
just we're doing it online because
essentially you're assassinating people
you're killing them you're you're
ripping their whole world away
everything is gone all the people that
you love the your business these things
that you've worked gone Boop gone
and and and we're doing that in in that
synthetic world that's that's that's
built and it's not very far from from
the reality the physical part of this
let me let me let me just uh
let's multiply the concerns here the
fears here
we used to have brick and mortar stores
we still do sort of you drive down any
Main Street in Old cities what do you
see most the stores are closed yeah it's
true there's there's there first there
was Walmart now there's Amazon it's all
online so people start building their
businesses on Twitter Facebook and
Google I knew a guy who would sell
things on his web store and all of his
traffic came from Google people would
search for something and he would be in
the top five
Google changed their algorithm one day
his search dropped to the second page
his business evaporated yeah there's no
second page now here's where it gets
crazy
many people are building businesses on
Twitter Facebook and Google selling
things promoting things being
commentators oops you got banned your
business is erased imagine this when we
live in Mark Zuckerberg's metaverse fake
reality that he desperately wants us to
live in and you create a store with a
virtual environment that sells t-shirts
and people can walk in and they can buy
stuff and they can chat and then Mark
Zuckerberg walks in with a smile on his
face and says I'm deleting your store
and then you're gone everything you
worked for ceases to exist like that you
have a brick and mortar store it's a lot
harder to do you go into the metaverse
with digital business they can ban you
out right we launch a store we sell
t-shirts we got a t-shirt pen you can
buy it if you want
the company that hosts it could just
erase that store instantly and then
we're not selling any products it is a
nightmarish potential future unless we
stay conscious of what's happening and
fight for right for rules where this
crypto story comes in right we see the
dollar coming apart our economy coming
apart we see this what's happening with
with the fpx
um and and and now that there's going to
be the big push for the the
cryptocurrency regulations and
everything that got to get their hands
in that and cash isn't going to work we
need these regulations and we're going
to attach that to the social credit
score and we're going to take away
everything that's in this physical the
brick and mortar gone so that then that
ultimate control you say something that
is not part of the narrative you say
something that goes again you're whoa
you're gone well sorry what do you what
are you gonna do two things you know how
to grow corn no no don't worry about it
you will owe nothing and you will be
happy you will live in the Pod and you
will eat the bugs you will eat z-bugs
my favorite meme right now okay well one
I shouldn't say that but like a meme I
really like is the chicken that says I
will live in the Pod I will eat the bugs
and I will give you eggs that's a good
one oh my gosh chickens are great you're
talking about female human eggs are they
gonna be harvesting people's eggs in a
laboratory yeah and right now you are
but I wanted the metaphor extends to the
next 70 years those goofy little things
run around eating bugs living in their
little pod and then we you know Kim goes
out there and she collects all their
little butt bounties crack them up and
have breakfast bring a little black
pepper on them can't be beef I've raised
chickens too yeah how many chickens you
got well we just had a weasel attack so
we're down yeah I raised Ducks too and
and weasel got in there big time so I I
lost upwards of nine ducks and three
chickens so my flock is down what
percent of your flock was that uh about
30 one weasel yeah it was actually two
my wife saw two a team of weasels yeah a
team of weasels they were working
together wow yeah
of Auto defense turret that can identify
what a chicken looks like yeah using an
AI and it like it pans past the chickens
and sees the weasel and it's great you
know it's crazy it gets so frustrating
sometimes you just at least not you you
know me I just say let's just burn it
all down I just want to burn the whole
Barn down it's it's it's incredible such
a little
little creature can cause so much damage
yeah we had we had a we had a snake get
in a couple times it was eating eggs but
the chickens are mostly fine the the
bigger issue we had is that um Roberto
Jr who is uh uh you know the son of
Roberto obviously and he's in charge his
mom died she had uh ovarian cancer
oh yeah yeah nothing we could do about
it we just didn't know that she just
said cancer we didn't see any signs she
died then we come to the the vet got a
check and they were like there's nothing
could have done just happens yeah yeah I
think you're you're burning how you're
saying sometimes you get so frustrated
that you want to burn the barn down a
lot of people are feeling that like
sociologically like they're so
frustrated with the system and a lack of
hope that they say burn it all down but
like then you you get a chance hopefully
you get a chance to remember how awesome
it is to be alive in this experience of
love and pleasure and like learning and
protecting keep other life and it you're
reminded that it's worth keeping around
uh yeah that's a that's a good that's a
good note Ian it's a good note we're
gonna go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends become a
member at timcast.com we're gonna have a
members only show coming up for you
about 11 p.m should be a whole lot of
fun and uh let's uh let's see what you
guys got Kenneth Hart says no way
Michael Graves man it was so cool
exchanging emails during Bush's
re-election campaign what changed how
did you evolve from there
um you know I'll be honest with you I
started to work more and get involved in
the in the
the military sphere of things and
talking to soldiers and really becoming
aware of of what was happening
um
with the war and in you know September
11th after what happened with September
11th and great work like Luke randowski
had done and learning
the the what was happening with 911
really started to wake me up I I fell
asleep when those Towers came down and
and I was living close enough to to
where I could see the smoke in the sky
uh to to New York City and I immediately
became in in entrenched in the in the
propaganda and got angry and got mad and
and forgot a lot of the stuff that
you've been you know you've been
following Luke for a long time I I know
Lou yeah of course sure he's a hero yeah
oh gee first first YouTube channel to be
demonetized I'm pretty sure bill ottman
was telling me one time he was in like
New York and at some rally and he was
like dude Luke was on a a statue like
right we are going to the building
right 911 was an inside job you know you
would always see you know well we had 10
000 uh you know people including family
members rescue workers survivors of 911
asking for some serious questions to be
answered and we were all over New York
City without apartment marching and not
an easy thing to do during those times
man no no there was agent provocateurs
there's people trying to of course make
us uh seem like we were crazier or just
information and bad messaging there's a
lot of cast sunstein types but those
days we were in the streets there the
internet wasn't as prominent people
didn't have cell phones that you could
interact with they had flip phones so
during those days we had to do
everything in the streets we were
bullhorning uh we were giving out
leaflets we were giving out DVDs we've
been doing that for for such a long time
and and the streets is where it was at
we're going to read some more we got
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim you know
I'm game I learned Lots from going out
earlier this year I'll knock on doors
and harvest the effort of ballots not
for Republicans for Maga for America
folks we got two years we can still win
that's right make sure you check in I
think it's 26 States there's regulations
on how what how many you can ballot
Harvest and if you can some states it's
like you can only bring in bouts if
they're your family members
there's many states where there's just
no regulation at all so people are
literally going door-to-day I'll take it
from you and they'll just take the
ballots and go drop them off is it
actually called bout harvesting
officially or like what do they call
ballot collection because harvesting
sounds dirty yeah I mean
it's whatever you want to describe it as
okay
designated designated
um what is it called if in a lot of
States they have like a designated agent
or something it's called where you sign
saying this person can can take my
ballot from me you know really says like
the the Democratic ground game right
that sounds like a ground game sort of
thing and always hear a lot about how
uh you know you have to get into the the
Republican you know Frank Kavanaugh uh
bass player filter who's a good friend
of mine is always talking about that
about you know getting in at the at some
sort of level where that sort of ballot
harvesting thing
um could be implemented you know
while full Sensei says really
disappointed daily wire is losing the
plot how so
oh I saw that super chat I didn't
understand though yeah I don't know are
they like anti-trump or something was
that what it is probably assume I'm
gonna look at their website now I think
Candace said she's going to be
interviewing him again at some point or
wants to Donald
okay what do we have Jay says did you
guys hear that the New York Lawyers who
threw the molotov at the cop car got
disbarred during the not peaceful George
Floyd protests
um I didn't hear that I did hear that
some woman got sentenced to six years
and also in the video I did talking
about how they're going after Trump for
the 14th with the 14th Amendment I
pointed out how Joe Biden basically his
campaign assisted the 529 Insurrection
and there was a story and it's
absolutely hilarious I think it was NBC
that said something like uh temporary
barricades removed and damaged to church
after peaceful protest becomes
destructive
I was like wait what
peaceful protest all right depends on
who's doing it is how yeah how it's
characterized right Dan Brockman says my
uh Michael famous monster as an American
Psycho were huge influences for my band
screaming torso from 06 to 08 please
look us up SoundCloud our album is
called there will be torso thank you
Michael screaming torso I love it all
right oh yeah man dude we'd go skating
and they'd be blasting your stuff like
my friends would just put it on and
that's we listen to that a bunch of
other punk rock stuff as we as we went
to go skate the local parks and stuff
like that how do they work Misfits have
been around before you joined the band
yeah Misfits were formed 1977 Lodi New
Jersey by Glenn Danzig uh Jerry Only uh
they broke up in 81 I think something
like that and then they really gained
popularity from bands like Metallica you
know Cliff Burton the the bass player
always had the this this go on and uh
like Rob Zombie and um so when I got
into the band it was there was a lot
more Legend behind the band than than
anything else they only had really only
had played a handful of shows and and so
everything was sort of Word of Mouth
um yeah yeah so I got an abandoned in
1995. sorry
fresh stuff when you hit or did you play
a lot of the old catalog when we first
went out we did a tour called the
resurrection tour and we did like every
song they ever wrote you know it was
incredible it was like 30 40 songs I
think a night uh back to back back to
back one two three go and then we would
go crypto crypto rat says Michael your
music saved my life brother you are one
of the greatest Poets of our time new
album soon
wow bless you thank you very much
again I'll I'll take that over over you
know Fame and celebrity or nice fancy
cars and everything I I'm I'm so blessed
that like I said I just came back from
this tour
um in in the United States an acoustic
tour and and I hear that all the time I
hear that that these profound stories
about people's lives and the things that
they've gone through and and how they've
overcome or or what they're currently
going through and for them to then say
that my music or something that I've
created is has affected them or it's
it's bound to them in some sort of way
is just is is that's treasure in heaven
that's not treasure down here it's an
amazing amazing thing and it it really
helps Propel me uh forward and right on
man so I don't just hide in the woods
and never
never show my face again not keep it up
Seth weather says Shameless self plug
our let's go Brandon Christmas wrapping
paper is back for 2022 with new designs
and it won't let me post the post to the
full link
brandonwrap..com that is the Seth
weather's there that's right yeah he was
on the show we got to get some of that
we should order some of that yeah let's
go Brandon wrap and then I can send out
presents to my family members and see
who gets triggered what was the website
again
brandonwrap.com I think Brandon wrapped
I'm gonna do the hammer thing so I think
at officialmicellgraves.com I'm gonna
sell hammers well people are policy
hammers we made jokes about like Banning
Hammers and like hammers with tactical
forward grips and like sights on them
and stuff like that
people start making memes
all right let's see potatoes for Sheamus
says surge feat cast IRL oh hey
what's up I could see that yeah
all right Grim Pickens says all right
hear me out what if underwear man is
Corn Pop
you know he'd be too young David to Pap
too young to be Corn Pop yeah What if
Paul Pelosi is Corn Pop now or now it's
making that's actually a conspiracy
theory that the pap guy for in in my
mind has this weird resemblance or
something that's that's similarly
strange strangely similar to the to the
FTX crypto guy I don't know why though
those FTX dudes were doing a lot of
drugs he would I've I've read it yeah
different drugs yeah maybe something in
the eyes like that that you know they
have the Crazy Eyes something Pluto the
ninth says Mr Graves you're an
incredible singer started listening as a
teen and had American Psycho on repeat
for years my four-year-old son loves it
too can you say giant spiders prepare to
take over for Abram giant spider yeah
giant spiders prepare to take over
dinner
right on
David Toronto says why are there no
pictures of Paul Pelosi after the attack
if they tried to blame it on a right
winger wouldn't they want people to see
he was hurt yeah or they can just say
whatever they want people believe it
yeah and charging that dude would
attempted murder yeah he plays not he's
pleading not guilty
all right what is this uh what we got
Ryan Philpot says just saw the Misfits
in Dallas with Danzig Jerry Only basis
is my cousin no matter who was the
singer Misfits Rock I'm excited to see
Graves is uh so so Danzig rejoined or
what yeah those guys buried the hatchet
for
um and and are have been doing shows for
for a couple years now it's like the
called the original Misfits so they got
they got Glenn Jerry and Doyle
um I don't know who they have drum and
they they had Dave Lombardo from Slayer
Drummond for him for a while do they
play your songs too no no no no they
they don't even mention me it's kind of
you know I'm sort of memory hold yeah
it's it's the it's old stuff I think now
they're doing like Walk Among Us and I
think yeah yeah could you retain the
rights to the stuff you wrote while
you're with the band uh yeah I go out I
play it I'm going to South America in
about a week and a half and I do famous
monsters I do American Psycho famous
monsters back to back cool
so I I I still wave the flag people love
the music you know but it those guys
getting me back in the in the can you
imagine if if you know I'm kind of
underground under the radar right now
with with what I'm doing for them to to
get me back in the band and do like
American Psycho famous monsters with
those guys
I I it wouldn't work because of all the
the BS that would come with it Malian
says when even Marjory Taylor green
voted for McCarthy my positivity on
Republicans doing anything meaningful
fell to zero
I get it though MTG wants to be on
committees she wants to be able to
actually get something done and so
they're probably saying look don't go up
against the RNC
give them what they want and they'll
give you something back
I kind of just think the GOP needed to
go in and be like nah
but we'll see if uh if Marjorie can get
things done look I I trust Marjorie
Taylor green so
that that one that one threw me for
through me a little bit I was like
really man
is it just like a big group of like a
fraternity sorority type thing where
they're all they all know each other and
it's all kind of understood like Mitch
you got this We're Not Gonna no it's
probably more like the people who have
been in the party the longest and have
been in office longest have more control
over over funding and who gets money and
how it gets spent so they basically say
I'm gonna be party leadership vote for
me otherwise I cut your funding and you
don't get reelected and we go up against
you look at what we did to these
candidates and these candidates and then
they're like okay okay
so someone it just needs to be like I'll
take two years I guess the problem is
everybody really really wants to be in
in office they want to get reelected
maybe term limits would be good I don't
know yeah if it were me I'd be like dude
you don't want to play a game of chicken
with me because I'll go nuts yeah like
if I'm gonna be here for two years it's
gonna be a really bad two years for you
how about we make it four years but we
kind of compromise that there's that
that sort of thing is very rare in in
people in in men and and women I mean
you see what's happened the past two
years look at January 6th all the
pressure that came down on on people and
whether it's proud boys or anybody else
everyone just scattered everyone just
scattered because of the downward
pressure and because of
you know the the fear it it really takes
a certain someone to stand on their
their two feet and and be firm in their
position and say no this is the right
thing I'm doing this because of
Integrity because of because of morals
and my alignment and I don't care what
you take from me that's the whole Give
me liberty or give me death people don't
understand that Give me liberty or give
me death take everything from me if you
want because it's not about me I mean to
a certain point it's about individualism
but it's about the people that came
before us and what they did and what
they built and sacrificed and it's for
the people that have are going to come
after us my children your children
everybody's children that's true I don't
feel like that's my motivation
necessarily maybe a little bit mine's
more like I'm more willing to sacrifice
than you are you know so if if if if
somebody wants to get involved in a game
of chicken that's the game the cars are
speeding at each other who's who's got
more to lose who's got less to lose and
who's going to bow out first I I
remember I learned this important lesson
from my dad when he was driving his
Wrangler which was a giant hunk of Steel
with with you know rust holes in it and
some luxury sedan was trying to
basically cut him off and push him out
of a zipper and he started laughing and
he was just like this guy's not going to
touch me and then sure enough the guy
slammed the brakes on and we kept going
and he was like you think the guy in
that expensive car is going to risk
damage to it I'm in a giant bucket full
of metal I don't care if someone hits it
and I'm like that's a funny way to look
at things so when I see somebody come at
me and I'm just like bro
you got to understand how leverage works
if if you know right now we've got 31
members I think of the House Freedom
caucus who are challenging McCarthy and
good for them but we need more people
who are going to be like
if I'm here for two years I'm here for
two years you better work with me or
you're going to regret it they might be
able to come out and be like we're going
to campaign against you we're going to
work against you we're going to ship you
have committees and I'm going to be
alike then I'm gonna make sure the next
two years are are worse off for you for
it or we can just say truce let's get
through this one and make it work you
know what I would do if I got into
Congress first thing is I would get 432
head shots is that how many people are
in the house 432 and I'd put them on my
wall and I would memorize everyone's
name and face this is what I did in
theater school when the new class would
come in I was like a sophomore all the
freshmen I would stare at their
headshots and memorize all their names
and it created a community so I knew
everybody when they would walk in I
don't know I kind of feel like they
maybe we're just scared of you
like I'm I'm imagining walking to a
school and like some dude I know walking
up being like hey Tim might be like uh
no they were glad because they were all
nervous and they were new and like you
can you can be be there for people and
help people you know find comfort in
these crazy high stress situations and I
think just being there for them the
people in Congress they need that right
now they need like emotional support
in addition to awesome policies like
pulling carbon dioxide out of here and
turning into graphene
let's read some more Christopher Hunter
says yo Michael great to see you on I'd
love to bring you back to Waco again
it's been too long much love to Tim cast
and crew keep it weird Ian I went to
Waco uh not that long ago went and
checked out the um the Branch Davidian
compound and got to see all the all the
stuff there me too yeah tremendous I was
just up in Waco I did a private show
um yeah for sure I stopped by the the
Branch Davidian compound there where
they have the they have that church and
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's crazy to
read all that stuff
things the US
is willing to do and for what reason I
have no idea
Mark Jones says FTX funded the Democrats
someone needs to investigate and report
and uh how much do you want to bet the
Republicans don't
because they were also getting
Investments yeah well uh a little bit
reportedly not as much as the Democrats
but they gotta they got a lot of money
but they should they should give back
that money the politicians who got the
money from FTX right now should give it
back to the people who had their money
stolen but it's not the politicians it's
the Pacs the politicians are legally
restricted on how much money they can
receive from an individual so what
happens you get these super Pacs that
just take in 200 400 million dollars and
and like it's a little seedy because it
wasn't just FTX it was a company called
Alameda research it was a sister company
and it was being ceoed by Sam bankman
Freed's girlfriend and it was they were
what it looks like is that FTX was
funneling money to Almeida Almeida was
doing the investment for them donkey
Paradise says Timothy with all due
respect you know better than to give a
pass on only fans and the like just ask
yourself the whole crew in fact just ask
each other how would I feel if my
daughter were doing this my son
supporting this horrifying much an
emotional con job evil
I get it
um the challenge is what I want my
family on only fans absolutely not do I
want to deprive the right of consenting
adults to exchange in Goods no I don't
but that's the difference between
libertarian and conservative
conservatives of course have no problem
saying like dude we are not going to
allow Society where women stop working
as police officers and nurses so that
they can become porn stars for
subscription fees and Libertarians are
kind of like as long as you're not
infringing on the rights of others
consenting adults can agree to what they
want
I don't know what do you guys think
about all these as long as there's
informed consent I I think people don't
know about the long-term kind of
negative consequences especially when it
comes to online pornography there's also
another argument to make here that uh
men wouldn't have access to him and if
it wasn't for that that men's depression
would go down because that there's a lot
of different arguments to make here but
it's a very complicated one since this
is such a new phenomenon that is taking
Society by storm and it's really hard to
quantify as of right now but overall uh
I don't think enough people know about
the dangers of pornography
yeah I'm kind of with you about consent
I think it's a big part of is do you
know what you're getting into here's
exactly here's the challenge uh this is
based on a story I did on Twitch there
are groomers who are going into the
channels of of young people and then
offering them donations and money and
subs in exchange for
certain activities that Grooms them into
doing worse and worse things young young
people young people so the study found
some of these are even prepubescent
children but they're typically like
young teenage girls yeah and so they'll
say hey do a handstand hey take your
socks off show me your feet and they
increment and get it crazier and crazier
and what they're doing is they're
grooming kids into becoming only fan
porn stars that's the that that's a
major problem it's one thing if like
some adult is like hey I want to send
some pics and get paid for it it's like
well concerning adults it's another
thing when you have people actively
grooming children for these things and
it causes social degradation yeah and
then we're gonna look in the metaverse
and only fans can easily morph into like
your digital avatars having sex with
their digital avatar for money and is
the kid even like 18 yet well a lot of
this boils down to the destruction of
the family unit which is which is one of
the key factors when it comes to the
larger takeover of society yeah sorry go
ahead that was all yeah I was I I I I I
have three children and uh I have a 13
year old and a 10 year old but have
access to the internet and I know
certainly what they're doing and what
they're looking at and what uh so again
it does it comes down to the degradation
of of the the family and and the parents
where where are the where are the
parents
that's where I get kind of know the
answer to that I'm saying I actually
find myself to be a little uh
obsessively authoritarian about family
life I try not to be yeah like I I used
to be lacks a days ago and do whatever
you want to do go do it but then she
starts you know stripping and like where
do you say no like where do you draw the
line in a relationship like how
informed consent we don't have any of
that yeah all right Yardbird says
unpopular opinion and I don't care
Michael Graves Misfits is way better
than Glenn Danzig Misfits about American
Psycho the day it dropped and I still
jam it Jam to it this day thank you
there you go Bruce so uh so bulvaro says
if you pre-order Earth simulacra 2 you
get pre-dementia Joe Biden for the
corruption DLC and extra campaign I need
to get pre-dimension Joe Biden yeah yeah
he's a limited edition yeah it's rare
plagiarism ability you can plagiarize
foreign diplomats and prayer cards can
we make a game like that that'd be
hilarious be a great card game is I
wonder if they can add you know into
like Civilization if someone can make an
expansion
yeah with a bunch of like modern world
leaders um uh you know what just let's
be real tremendous think about how
amazing it would be if you could play
Civilization and play As Trump or Biden
or Obama or Hillary like trying to
negotiate with Trump and civilization
would just be hilarious it'd be cool to
play as corporations
uranium or we're going to war it's like
I would prefer to avoid that I'm going
to Nuke you see and you can slap Trudeau
oh yeah I mean I wonder if they they
probably it sounds like a reasonable
thing they'd actually have maybe there's
uh no they have to be able to do that
maybe there's like a likeness issue or
something or copyright I don't know
okay
Bree Sullivan says Luke you've said that
we have to hold our politicians feet to
the fire short of an actual fire pit how
do we actually do that
uh don't support them unless they
actually are doing the right things I I
think anyone I I think we also have to
culturally you know make fun of people
that that worship politicians and then
make them uh their whole entire
personalities I I think people need to
be ostracized for saying the
politician's going to solve everything
in my life I think culturally that's
important I think also understanding our
power and and and building communities
and networks where we aren't dependent
on government is also another way to do
that
um and I think being open to to
criticizing your own side and all
politicians is another key step that's
important towards not just going along
with the cult of personality
waffle Sensei says do you think Trump
could beat Putin in a fistfight Putin is
like a trained assassin I know but he's
so tiny and he acts afraid of trump oh
Putin would rip him up in a fight yeah
because he's because I think he's a
Jujitsu yeah I think he knows a black
belt yeah and um in a fist fight okay
fair point if grappling's out of the
question and we're boxing I mean that's
a good question because Trump's got
height and reach and Mass
but uh but they're both really old
they're so old
money's on the train fighter no yes I
agree if it was a straight straight up
fight put no doubt because he's got the
grapple techniques yeah even if Trump
got to jump on him with like a chair I
think Putin would still like take one
and then be like oh it looks like Putin
might be quicker than him too he's just
got to get on the inside yeah work the
inside yeah if he gets close get in
close you're getting close
but size matters but like Tyson you know
someone would get in there Trump could
sit on him Trump would be like the Hulk
or the blob in X-Men and he'd like walk
up and Putin would like hit him in the
chest and Trump would just jiggle and go
yeah and be like oh no you have to use
special techniques on this guy
I don't know though I remember when that
guy tried
yeah what if what if this what if
instead of War we had world leaders
fight each other yeah absolutely
freaking great yeah yeah and then all
you and then you basically just like you
want a world leader who's ripped and a
well-trained fighter and who's got
experience in combat and then land
dispute what are we disputing this
territory how far in okay here's the
arena Joe Rogan's commentating we get
Dana White to run the whole thing they
used to do it out of necessary Rocky two
two opposing armies would come up and
rather than kill each other they'd be
like send their best warrior to the
front they duel whoever won would win
the battle then they wouldn't kill each
other and they'd be like okay you've
made your point but wouldn't it but now
then they invented ballistics and now
they're like any any monkey can blast
somebody yeah
I'm in the middle of some important
administrative work yes
all right
back to where we were quad we'll grab uh
we'll grab a couple more Super chats
Lily Lillian Mae Briggs says McCarthy is
the same as Ryan
yep yeah there you go
juice cyber new type says the media will
get revived willing to bet certain
investors will make sure they can while
Trump runs
Perhaps Perhaps I don't know I mean
what's with Twitter I'm also here's what
I'm worried about Matt is lying people
often on the downturn
Twitter is lying people off and people
are questioning you know what's going on
is going to last tick tock's expanding
yeah interesting but even even Democrats
are now talking about banning Tick Tock
so they better yeah yeah that's just
funneling all your data to China and
then messing with your kids it's a mind
control device 100 literally yeah
all right dirt nap 66 says Tim Biden is
as a ghoul in Fallout I mean it wouldn't
take but a slight skin tone change
agreed my friends if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have an
uncensored members only show coming up
for you tonight in about 45 minutes or
so you don't want to miss it you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me at timcast follow the show on
Instagram Tim castira we put Clips up
every day and uh Michael do you want to
shout anything out
I'll go check out
officialmichaelgraves.com uh working on
a bunch of really cool things also go
check out uh American libertyawards.com
it's a project that I'm working on uh
with Matt Baker and uh Frank Kavanaugh
from from from filter on more uh
information and things will come up
about that as we were talking about uh
parallel economies and things that we
can do to get culture back American
libertyawards.com are you on social
media uh I'm on Twitter at Radio deadly
and
um I'm on gab I'm on Rumble parlor again
officialmicogrades.com will have all of
the different social sites that I'm on
sweet well thank you so much for coming
on Michael this was great and it was an
awesome conversation awesome to have you
here
um as you guys know YouTube and
Instagram are giving me the business
that's why it's more important than ever
you guys check out Luke uncensored.com I
did an exclusive video there about what
I'm doing to prepare there's crazy times
ahead of us there's it's only going to
get crazier from here I detailed what
I'm doing and you could join the
conversation and my Forum all on Luke
uncensored.com check it out hope to see
you there and if you guys want to go to
Michael's website again it's
officialmichaelgraves.com it's Michael
m-i-c-h-a-l-e different than the way my
brother spells his name yeah Michael
great to see you buddy thanks and hey
guys check out cast castle if you
haven't seen it yet timcast.com this
week's episode is lit it was an honor to
have Cora nemec do an episode with us I
mean he he Parker Lewis Can't Lose
Stargate um we had someone in the Super
Chat tell me if you know a while back
they're like Tim if you're a fan of Star
Trek watch star Stargate sg1 I did it's
an amazing show coronamic of course
Jonas Quinn in the show and so having
him come here and and do a bit with with
Ian was awesome he's a blast to work
with so fun and I think it shows up in
the in the movie itself in the show
itself so check it out definitely gotta
check it out we watched a couple
episodes before we got on here I had
never saw it before the one where Ian
Jam stuff uh Jam stuff up his ass was
also very funny yeah that's last week's
episode no joke and you should
definitely check that out as well that
was my idea yeah I think we're joking
that's actually what he's absolute yeah
I'm the Mind genius behind that just a
heads up and I'm search.com hope you
guys liked today I was going we will see
you all over at timcast.com become a
member and once a week we're gonna I
don't even know if we're gonna do five
people we're gonna try and grab just a
handful five a minimum five but maybe
more of the people who comment on our
members only content and we're just
going to hit you up and be like where
can we send you some some schwag and
knickknacks from the show and um it
might often be a funny thing like you
might get a piece of garbage like
nothing gross but like I don't know like
Luke's notepad or something or what Ian
inserted into himself no I would love to
send you that but like Ian's rocks or
something like that whatever whatever
we're trying to get rid of off the table
Yeah so uh thanks for hanging out
everybody and we will see you all over
at timcast.com cheers